[Musique]
en france tous les trois jours un
agriculteur ou une agricultrice se
suicider pourtant vous et moi prenons
deux à trois repas par jour
connaissez-vous vraiment les
agriculteurs qui travaillent derrière
ces robins en 2010 avec d'autres
collègues agriculteurs nous sommes posé
une question comment être agriculteur en
2020 nous avons essayé d'y répondre
je vais vous expliquer ma renaissance
celle qui fait que je suis là
aujourd'hui avec vous
je m'appelle fabrice second je suis
agriculteur issus de trois à quatre
générations d'agriculteurs viticulteurs
paysans et je suis très fier des gens
qui dans ma famille on fait ce métier
tellement fier que lorsque j'étais
petite à l'école primaire
cette fierté m'a joué des tours isolé
harceler mis de côté parce que dans les
années 80 est fils d'agriculteur c'était
pas bien j'aurais pu devenir violent me
révolter comme ça a été dit avant j'ai
plutôt choisi d'être le premier de la
classe
mon parcours j'ai voulu être sportif de
haut niveau sportif après les blessures
sont arrivés a fallu changer écoles de
compta école de commerce
j'ai trouvé un travail autour des
agriculteurs pendant 15 ans j'ai visité
300 exploitations laitières ou je suis
aidé les agriculteurs qui tous les jours
ma porte est un vrai plaisir dans le
travail un jour j'ai fait une rencontre
12 décembre 2000 d'un peu trop près
peut-être
c'était une voiture choc frontal comme a
déclaré mort de leur ennemi de
désincarcération hôpital trois mois
alité trois autres mois pour s'en
remettre
ces trois mois alité le plafond pour
repenser tout ce que vous avez fait mais
vous pensez surtout à ce que vous allez
pouvoir faire
pourquoi est ce que la vie est belle
elle vaut d'être vécue
comment donner du sens à ce qu on fait
comment on ne pas accepter ce qu'on vous
impose
en 2005 je fais le choix de revenir sur
l'exploitation familiale travailler avec
mon frère avec parents avec mes parents
devenir agriculteur paysans ce retour
est voulu ce retour on a choisi de le
faire différemment avec mon frère en
modifiant notre modèle agricole problème
en 2009 une grave crise des tiers
arrivant et je pense qu'ici tout le
monde s'en souvient des éleveurs ont
décidé de faire la grève du lait de
jeter leur production ce jour là avec
d'autres collègues nous avons compris
que plus rien ne serait comme avant
qu'on ne pouvait plus se laisser faire
et nous avons décidé de nous même monter
notre propre projet mais pas contre le
système pas contre les autres démontré
qu'on pouvait faire autrement
donc à quatre éleveurs deux
exploitations
nous avons décidé de produire
transformer et vendre nous mêmes notre
production faire nos propres choix
produire pas difficile pour
l'agriculteur si pourtant la tradition
faire ce que papa fait déjà depuis 25
ans lui même creusé de là depuis des
années que changer le modèle de
production très difficile produire
autrement sans ogm sans huile de palme
dans une filière où nous pouvons mesurer
l'impact l'impact nutritionnels pour les
animaux mais aussi pour les amants
l'impact environnemental
environnementale pour notre planète nous
faisons ce choix là mais nous faisons le
choix d'aller plus loin en voulant
transformer transformer notre propre
production
et là on nous prend pour des foules
imaginez des agriculteurs qui gagnent
moins de 350 euros par mois vouloir
monter une laiterie à 8 millions 5,2
euros pour le faire imaginez les banques
imaginée l'entourage qu'on leur annoncer
sa fenêtre créatif
mais a fallu deux persévérant une fois
que vous faites ça et vous avez envie
vous allez le dire
et ce jour là nous avons lancé un
financement participatif qui nous a
permis d'avoir un million six cent mille
euros avec des consommateurs des acteurs
des gens qui voulaient eux aussi nous
encourager à changer et grâce à ça nous
avons pu construire notre laiterie
d'avion changer de modèle de production
nous avons construit restait avant d'en
connaissait grand méchant loup jus des
agriculteurs c'est le monde de la grande
surface interdit d'y aller on s'est
serré les coudes et on était les voir
discuter expliquer expliquer que le
modèle est en train de disparaître et
qu'il fallait en créer un autre
expliquait qu'il était important pour
eux comme pour nous de travailler
ensemble et on a trouvé des vrais
partenaires nous avions donc changer
notre modèle de production à voir notre
outil de transformation et vendre mais
pour cela il restait un énorme effort
celui de changer changer
humainement parce que vouloir le
changement je pense qu'ici tout le monde
le veut le changement mais êtes-vous
prêt vous individuellement a changé
parce que changer demande beaucoup
d'efforts pour les agriculteurs isolés
dans leur ferme
seul il fallait devenir agri
entrepreneurs se former à prendre de
nouveaux métiers manager à les vendre
mais aussi gérer aujourd'hui je peux
vous le dire je pense que nous avons
réussi nous avons réussi pourquoi nous
avons fait 9 millions chiffre d'affaires
l'année dernière l'entreprise est à
l'équilibré
treize collaborateurs sont avec nous à
travailler tous les jours nous pouvons
mesurer notre impact environnemental
un litre de lait notre production c'est
un kilomètre de voitures économiser le
pouls
mesurer notre impact nutritionnelles sur
la santé sur la santé de nos animaux et
sur la santé des hommes
tout ça ça c'est fait grâce à des
rencontres
nous sommes partis du principe que nous
n'avions de limites que celles que nous
on se fixe est alors je sais les gens
qui me connaissent le dit ce que j'en ai
pas mais j'en ai pas parce que j'ai
toujours voulu aller de l'avant j'ai
toujours voulu apprendre plus à prendre
difficile pour un agriculteur isolé mais
quand on prend conscience de qui on est
de ce que l'on veut tout peut arriver à
faire des rencontres on croise plein de
gens mais ne croyait pas que les grands
hommes sont toujours là où vous pensez
qu'ils sont une de mes rencontres
préférée celle qui a donné le plus de
sens au projet dans sa globalité était
haut comme ça il avait 9 ans rencontré
au détour d'une animation dans un
magasin le petit bonhomme nous passe
devant prend deux packs de lait les
mettre dans son caddie et s'en va le
papa tout honteux arrive derrière en lui
demandant s'il connaissait notre lait le
petit fait demi tour et fait ouais mais
ton lait il est pas bon il a goût de
lait de vache comme aujourd'hui je pense
que j'ai fait humble ses reins mais en
fait ce petit garçon en disant ça net de
valider 50 travaillent cinq ans de
rencontres 55 riz fils pour construire
ce qu'on voulait notre laiterie pouvant
transformer notre lait et pour des
agriculteurs
c'est une vraie fierté donc oui des
rencontres on en a fait des gens sont
venus spontanément nous aider par le
financement participatif mais aussi dans
la formation des agriculteurs
c 'est rencontres qui font
qu'aujourd'hui on peut vivre dignement
de notre métier mais qu'on peut être
fier de ce qu'on a fait donc aujourd'hui
ce pourquoi celle là c'est aussi vous
montrer que en étant un prenant et non
sachant on peut dépasser ses limites
peut aller bien au delà des règles qu'on
se fixe et j'ai une fierté aujourd'hui
une de plus peut-être certains diront
c'est que les éleveurs faisant partie de
l'aventuré sont devenus agri
entrepreneurs ma fierté
elle s'appelle alex
dominique éleveurs qui aujourd'hui sont
responsables ressources humaines
s'appelle antoine et simon responsable
recrutement de l'ensemble des éleveurs
et du suivi qualité de la production
d'amiens et sébastien mon petit frère
responsable du développement du r&d et
de la maintenance de l'entreprise et
yvan et nicolas imaginez deux éleveurs
pour les gens qui sont en qualité ont
pour projet dans deux ans d'emmener
l'entreprise ali et fès la norme la plus
haute de l'agroalimentaire au monde
ce sont deux éleveurs et enfin patrice
égale qui sont responsables de 20 de
notre développement au niveau des
cantines restauration collectivités
ma fierté elle l1 aujourd'hui ma fierté
c'est eux eux qui ont décidé d'être des
acteurs du changement qui ont décidé de
sortir de l'euro et nous allemands et
d'aller à la rencontre des autres et je
terminerai par cette phrase qui nous
touche beaucoup nous dans le monde
agricole parce qu'on est en lien avec la
nature
c'est que l'arbre qui tombe dans le
forez fait souvent plus de bruit que la
forêt qui pousse c'est une forêt une
partie de la forêt qui pousse
vous pouvez être une autre partie de
cette forêt merci
[Musique]